some dramatic video for you this morning
an attack on a police officer in
Northern Virginia this is just outside
Washington D.C and in the video you're
about to see it shows the officer
struggling with a suspect who then
shoves him into his own Cruiser which
then crashes into a nearby McDonald's
and that believe it or not was not the
end of it Nancy Chen has more
those screams by
fifth officer in Richmond going out over
the radio as he struggled with a robbery
suspect Witnesses captured this footage
of the struggle between the two men by a
gas station the officer had engaged the
man while responding to reports he had
stolen this U-Haul truck the assailant
in this matter shoved our police officer
into the open front driver's door of his
marked police car and was attacking him
was on top of him with both men inside
the officer's vehicle spins in Reverse
crashing into a McDonald's next door at
the same time the officer is calling for
backup and saying the suspect had his
gun
other officers rushing to help one of
them firing several rounds
another officer pulls a suspect from the
vehicle and fires three routes killing
the suspect who was yet to be named the
officer who was in the vehicle was taken
to the hospital with minor injuries
Fairfax County's police chief says while
the suspect did grab the officer's gun
he never fired it and had body cam
footage has yet to be released I have
never quite seen something like this now
that police officer was literally inside
of his own police car fighting for his
life
wow that was Nancy Chen reporting I'm
just not sure exactly what we were
looking at but I think if you grab an
officer's gun that sort of changes the
whole dynamic you were looking at this
whatever was happening you were looking
at the suspect pushing his way into the
officer's Cruiser that was not the
officer but the suspects wonder if
there's body cam video yeah a lot of
questions